ja ich wünschte es wäre hier sowie
programms aus der ukraine berichtete was
krone angeht dass es hier auch nicht
mehr real wäre wir haben heute seit
heute eine einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht das klingt sehr technisch
das klingt sehr sehr indirekt
tatsächlich sind rund wie jeder siebte
deutsche arbeitnehmer arbeitsplatz
innere aber ist betroffen von der
pflicht sich gegen profit 19 impfen
lassen zu müssen weil er oder sie
mittelbar einen arbeitsplatz im
gesundheitswesen hat und das ist ein
rechter zivilisationsbruch es ist eine
politische gewalttat weil hier
eingegriffen wird in die körperliche
unversehrtheit gesunder menschen ich als
einfacher notarzt darf patienten nur
gegen ihren willen behandeln unter sehr
engen bedingungen nämlich nur dann wenn
ich den unmittelbaren tod und das
unmittelbare schwere leid abwende und
zwar nicht auf hand irgendwelcher
wahnvorstellungen eines karl lauterbach
der theoretische möglichkeiten immer
wieder herbei fantasie hat sondern ich
brauche ganz konkreten anhalt dass er
oder sie sich selbst schädigen wird weil
er klar sagt ich denke mich umzubringen
oder einen dritten schädigt nur dann
darf ich diesen menschen zwingend
behandelt zu werden und jetzt haben wir
substanz nehmen und auf arzneimittel mit
schweren nebenwirkungen die verabreicht
werden zwangsweise respektive wenn ich
sie dann nicht nehmen ich diese
indirekte zwang dann ist mein
arbeitsplatz eben weg die
bewiesenermaßen bewiesenermaßen keinen
dritten schützen können und auch
keinerlei überlastung des
gesundheitssystems abwenden müssen oder
können das ist ein absoluter kulturbruch
es ist eine vollkommene überschreitung
aller rechtsstaatlichen grenzen und es
ist eine politische gewalt hat dringend
gestoppt werden ist
eine politische gewalt hat das scheint
mir doch direkt mal zu wolfgang bosbach
tut sich die regierung mit der
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht
eingefallen oder ist es hip hop
brandenburg ausgedruckt hat wer eine
gewalttat am bürger
ich glaube nicht dass sich die regierung
damit einen gefallen tut ich würde aber
darum bitten differenziert zu
argumentieren als jemand der zwei mal
geimpft ist und zweimal gemeistert und
sich danach also nach vier impfungen
infiziert hat würde ich trotzdem für das
impfen werben weil ich so gut wie
überhaupt keine symptome hat aber es ist
ein unterschied ob ich für das eben von
werbe und mich freiwillig impfen lassen
oder ob ich zwangsweise durch staatliche
anordnung geimpft werden muss es ist
noch nicht lange her da hat mich ein
repräsentant eines großen trägers
händeringend darum gebeten dass die
impfpflicht nicht kommt weil er
befürchtet dass es kontraproduktiv sein
könnte denn sie betrifft ja nur menschen
die sich nicht freiwillig lassen ich
füge hinzu wenn wir eine sterile
immunität garantieren könnten würde ich
das anders sehen aber warum musste ich
in quarantäne als jemand der firma
geimpft worden ist doch offensichtlich
weil ich virus träger war und andere
hätte infizieren können es stimmt also
nicht dass diejenigen die geimpft sind
so geschützt sind dass sie andere nicht
infizieren können wir haben mit der
impfpflicht die pocken ja die haben wir
nun wirklich dass wenn der grund beim
besser wissen als ich behaupte dass
jetzt mal kühn weltweit ausgerottet aber
wir haben hier keine oder leider noch
keinen impfstoff mit dem wir eine
sterile immunität garantieren können es
ist noch nicht lange her da hat herr
spahn in seiner rolle als
gesundheitsminister gesagt ich
garantiere ihnen das wird keine
impfpflicht geben auch lauterbach selber
war einmal kritiker der impfpflicht
ich kann mir das nur so vorstellen dass
so eine art vorratsbeschluss gefasst
wird für möglicherweise eine welle die
im winter kommen könnte schloss als von
mir das wesentliche argument seit zwei
jahren war immer keine überlastung
unseres gesundheitssystems warum jeder
der ernsthaft erkrankt ist und
medizinisch behandlung braucht muss auch
behandelt werden können wir sind gott
sei dank trotz sehr hohe inzidenz sind
wir meilenweit von einer überlastung
unseres gesundheitssystems entfernt also
dieses argument fällt weg als jurist bin
ich natürlich gespannt wie karlsruhe
entscheiden der boss macht sicher ist
darüber einigkeit geben schlimmer noch
sie haben wir das entscheidende gesagt
nicht die freiwilligkeit ist das
absolute stichwort das ist völlig
richtig jeder der das freiwillig möchte
der soll das recht haben die möglichkeit
sich behandeln zu lassen mit diesem
impfstoff das ist vollkommen klar aber
das zweite was sie sagt ist ja der punkt
nicht die überlastung des
gesundheitssystem hat ist so niemals
gegeben nicht dieser herr lauterbach hat
eine unendliche kette von lügen
aufgetischt diese zeitung dieser verlag
hat ja viele davon entfernt und immer
wieder auch betitelt dieser mann ist ein
berufsmäßiger lügner und hetzer
verbreitet absolute lügen über
angebliche intensivbetten knappheiten
nicht über schreckliche wirkung auf
junge eltern kinder würden jetzt die
ihre eltern verlieren er zeichnet immer
wieder schlimmste horror szenarien
nichts davon war real diese lügen sind
alle aufgeflogen und die krönung des
ganzen erleben wir jetzt gerade wenn man
mal schaut unser deutsches
gesundheitssystem kostet im jahr rund
300 milliarden euro das ist eine
unglaubliche summe rund 11 prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes das argument war
immer wir haben dieses geld nicht dieses
gesundheitssystem zu retten nun ist mit
einem fingerschnipsen genau diese summe
von 300 milliarden ja aufgetaucht für
neue waffen für die bundeswehr für
energie politische ideologien der damen
und herren dort in rot grün aber das
gesundheitssystem konnte angeblich nur
gerettet werden mit dieser impfung die
ja medizinisch versorgt sagen wir es
ganz ehrlich es tut mir leid auch wenn
sie gewusst und geimpft hat er gewusst
hat sind nach der impfung also das ganze
ist ein fürchterliches lügengebäude es
gibt keine überlastung abzuwenden und
selbst wenn hätte man wohl offenbar auch
noch geld gehabt das zu tun das ist eine
katastrophe fehler darf man morgen
zwischen eine zwischenfrage nur das ist
das ist ein wichtiger punkt das hat die
bundesregierung selbst eingeräumt
bundesweit aber hat es denn nicht
tatsächlich kliniken gegeben die
überlastet waren mit der folge dass
patienten abgewiesen
mussten für planbare operationen oder
dass man andere kliniken um deren
aufnahme gebeten hat so dass es eine
partielle ist völlig richtig aber es
macht aber da muss man auch für das sagt
das ist in der intensivmedizin leider
tägliches geschäft immer zu den
erkältungswelle zu den grippewellen zu
den saisonalen häufung von infektionen
haben wir diese überlastung ich als
notarzt im bereich berlin-brandenburg
häufig damit beschäftigt gewesen so
genannte sekundär verlegung zu machen
das ist der technische terminus dafür
wenn so eine klinik voll ist und die
patienten verlegen müssen das ist
relativ normal erklärt sich durch das
bezahlungssystem im gesundheitswesen man
kann vereinfacht sagen eine
intensivstation muss immer voll sein
damit sie sich trägt so etwas wie eine
freie intensivstation gibt es nicht
ansonsten fällt sie weg da ist also
immer höchstens ein oder zwei betten
sind da frei oder werden dafür verwendet
so ist das system aufgebaut das ist
vollkommen normal anders herum gesagt
unsere intensivstation sind seit vielen
jahren überlastet das personal ist stark
überlastet das ist aber alles alt und
einer der hauptverantwortlichen täter
für diese chronische überlastung ist
heute gesundheitsminister der hat dieses
system auf dieses die ag system und ein
personal system ein arbeitsteam ein
schichtsystem was die menschen wirklich
auf den knochen bremsen lässt das dafür
sorgt dass wir rekrutierungsprobleme
haben insbesondere bei der pflege also
die überlastung ist real da hat auch
crooner mit reingespielt aber corona war
eben nicht kausal es war eine
überlastung mit corona aber nicht eine
überlastung ankommen ich bin ja auch
eine die oft und gerne karl lauterbach
kritisiert hat hier auch in der sendung
ich muss sagen er ist aber immer wieder
gekommen also egal was wir gemeinsam es
auch kriegen kommen hat sich dem dialog
gestellt das hat mir schon respekt
abverlangen der ist immer eine frage an
dich greift darf man karl lauterbach als
hetzer bezeichnen wie es dr
brandenburger ja ich wäre mit dem mit
dem wort weil er ja ohnehin von vielen
inflationär verwendet wird etwas
sparsamer
auch franz müntefering hat vor jahren
schon mal gesagt es sei ziemlich unfair
politiker immer an ihren worten von
gestern zu messen
ja gut
dass das problem weiß ich einfach sehe
ist die logische lücke die sich immer
mehr menschen erst erschließt
andererseits dürfen wir auch nicht
vergessen 58 prozent sagen in unserer
letzten umfrage vom letzten wochenende
immer noch sie sind für eine impfpflicht
unter anderem weil sie selbst oft sind
und das doof finden dass andere es nicht
sind dem kann man aber natürlich
entgegen halten wenn wir täglich mehr
als 100.000 infizierte haben dann ist
irgendwann die impflücken aufgebraucht
das heißt also wenn es nur um diejenigen
dinge aus denen die infektionen sich
speist die nicht geimpft sind dann
werden die nach einer woche alle krank
gewesen das problem ist tatsächlich bh
postbank vielfach geimpft und und schon
wieder in quarantäne
die impfung ist eine normale medizin sie
ist eine art biologisches pflaster sie
wirkt nicht als das wo wir früher
impfungen definiert haben wir willkommen
noch eines mit dem der einsatz nach
zuhören dr brand warum es gibt ja auch
sie sind mediziner es gibt viel kritik
von medizinern an den an den maßnahmen
und ganz verrückt ist was ich hier
gefunden habe aus den reihen des
gesundheitsministeriums gibt es vom 22
februar eine ein factsheet fragen und
antworten eben zu dieser einrichtung
bezogenen impfprävention impfpflicht
untersteht um eigentlich zitiert um eine
eintragung und weiterverbreitung des
virus in diesem setting es eben bei den
pflegepersonal zu vermeiden ist es
unerlässlich dass das dort tätige
personal vollständig geimpft ist ralf
kurz darauf hingewiesen wir haben jeden
tag mehr als 100.000 200.000 260.000
infizierte also die impfung und dazu
kommen wir gleich schützt nicht wie wohl
auch noch zeit für dein thema